es gab heute einen heftigen angriff auf
ein wohnviertel auch auf eine schule
erst das erlebt heute ungefähr oben 99
flog haben wir informationen bekommen
sie gehören diese explosion in norwegen
fällt ihm sofort hingefahren und habe
gesehen wie es im wohngebiet für meine
schule kindergarten und
einzige theater von vorne kette
schule im kindergarten
zerstört
sechs
bleiben weil ja die
zustand
einen menschen menschen gestorben
der vier kinder verletzt und 19 menschen
im krankenhaus gebracht
dass es noch keine zeichen
eine junge formation
weil die greifen wenn die bilder direkt
die greifen am ufer des städte zerstören
um seine stärke ist dass er wenig später
die
pastorin butia
bagger dass die stücke gibt nicht mehr
reguliert ein video von der das berühmt
geworden und millionenfach geteilt
worden würde ich an reporter gefragt hat
der aber putin sagt doch sind
militärische ziele und du sagst bullshit
richtig dass auf mittlerweile dass viele
immer noch putin zitiert
das ist eine lüge das ist was propaganda
verbreitet will sie in probleme gegen
die extremisten faschisten stimmt ich
war solche angriffe faschisten man kann
nennen nur russen weil die
umbringen frauen kinder
c alle zivilisten die gewinnen wir
sprechen für sie selbst wir haben
gesehen dass sind mario pohl bereits 80
prozent der wohnungen zerstört sind hast
du als käfer bürgermeister sorge dass
genau diese angriffe hunderte bomben
jeden tag elf zukommt die schlüssel
nicht aus dass es genau das ist wirklich
attraktiv
von vorne russen weil wir eine
marktmacht das ist ein ziel behaupten
ukraine zuzugucken das ist sehr viel
zivilisten sind gestorben in haiti von
mario private stellen er und ich habe
schon gesagt wir als menschen gesprochen
wie kann es sein dass trotzdem so viele
menschen hier bleiben du hast gesagt
wieder kommt zurück fast über zwei
millionen tiere noch
weil die frauen gehen wir am meisten
kinder schon in sichere da die ukraine
nach westen
gefahren
haben bereits wenige blieben weil er die
jede sagt sie haben längst in andere
länder und andere städte zu suchen das
so sehr teil maßstab dass es
unsere busse her das ist der caravan und
unsere familie wir sollten unsere stadt
unsere familie und unsere zukunft jetzt
gibt es immer wieder debatten auch in
deutschland über friedensverhandlungen
wladimir putin bietet das an jenes an
wird dann im telefonat mit olaf scholz
den ukrainer informativ bereit beim zu
sprechen wie siehst du diese prinz
verhandlung
[Musik]
ist dass es
eine kampagne zu viel in münchen
companies will ich möchte noch eine
sache müssen
herausgegeben
riesendusel krieg muss stoppen